Das ist "Mona mittendrin" -
drei Tage auf der Neonatologie.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich zeige dir das WC,
damit du dich umziehen kannst.
So.
Wunderbar. Schick.
- Schon bin ich mittendrin,
in einer Welt, die ich bisher
noch nie von innen gesehen habe.
Wir gehen extra
von hinten nach vorne.
Je nachdem wie lange die Familien
hier sind bzw. wie krank sie sind,
starten sie oft
hier hinten im Intensivzimmer.
Dann wandert man nach vorne, bis
zum Ausgang, um nach Hause zu gehen.
Das ist etwas Psychologisches.
Die Eltern
können das visuell wahrnehmen.
Sie merken,
dass sie einen Schritt weiter sind.
Was für Babys hat es hier?
Im Moment haben wir
gerade wirklich kleine Kinder.
So um 500 g herum.
- Frühgeburten?
Genau, aber auch Babys, die direkt
nach der Geburt schon krank sind.
Also Neugeborene,
die grössere Schwierigkeiten haben,
starten im Intensivzimmer.
Da geht es schon am Anfang des Lebens
um Leben und Tod.- Ja.
Da ist dieses Thema sehr nahe.
Leben oder Tod? Welches Leben?
Jetzt sagen wir mal kurz Hallo.
Debbie, wir sagen kurz Hallo.
- (Flüsternd) Hallo.
Hier im Intensivzimmer
liegen die kleinsten Patienten
des Kantonsspitals Aarau.
Das ist einer der Zwillingsbuben,
Trim.
Da musst du dich direkt bewegen, hm?
Anfangs sind sie stark abgedeckt,
damit sie möglichst viel Ruhe haben,
damit kein Licht oder Lärm
an sie herankommt.
So kann man das etwas filtern.
Darum sind die Tücher da.
Ich spreche auch automatisch leiser.
Man merkt das.
Mhm. Darum ist es hier ziemlich
ruhig, auch wenn viel los ist.
Das erdet einen auch,
wenn man so ruhig arbeitet.
Sie kamen mit 24 Wochen
und zwei Tagen zur Welt.
Das sind so die Jüngsten ...
... die man auf der Neonatologie
intensiv pflegt
und medizinisch betreut
und begleitet.
24 Wochen?
D.h., dass sie 16 Wochen zu früh
gekommen sind.
Also vier ...
- Vier Monate zu früh, genau.
Trim ist nur 500 g schwer.
Er kann noch nicht selber atmen -
das übernimmt eine Beatmungsmaschine.
Heute Morgen
erhält Trim eine Bluttransfusion.
Sein kleiner Körper
kann noch nicht genug Blut bilden.
Im Mutterleib
hätte Trim noch die Unterstützung
des Kreislaufs und der Plazenta
seiner Mutter.
Das ist eine Blutdruckmanschette,
die natürlich viel kleiner ist
als bei uns.
Die kommt ans Bein.
Während der Transfusion ...
... überwachen wir den Blutdruck.
- Meine Güte, das Füsschen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Jedes Kind hat einen Oktopus im Bett,
um sich daran festzuhalten.
Man sagt mir, die Tentakel erinnern
an die Nabelschnur im Mutterbauch.
Das beruhige und verhindere, dass sie
an den Kabeln und Schläuchen ziehen.
Ein eindrückliches Bild
mit den Fingern.
Neben Trim
liegt sein Zwillingsbruder Yll.
Der grüne Schlauch
ist der Beatmungsschlauch.
Der geht wirklich
die Luftröhre runter.
Er ist mit Kleber und Faden
gut fixiert.
Wenn wir merken,
dass sie die Finger stark brauchen,
kommt wieder der Oktopus ins Spiel
oder wir lagern sie anders.
Zusammen mit Stephi
darf ich Yll etwas zu trinken geben.
Achte darauf,
dass du gut desinfizierst.
Du gehst ja bis zur Ellenbeuge rein.
- Ja.
Also wirklich bis nach hinten
desinfizieren.- Ja.
Du darfst mit beiden Händen rein.
Leg die untere Hand auf ihn.
Ja, genau.
Und diese?
- Und jetzt ganz sanft.
Sanft drücken?
- Genau.
Muttermilch
gibt es über eine Spritze.
Wo geht das bei ihm jetzt hin?
Das geht über den transparenten,
weissen Schlauch
in den grünen Schlauch
und so in das andere Nasenloch.
Dann geht es direkt über
die Speiseröhre in den Magen.- Ja.
Man hat gar nicht das Gefühl,
dass man ihm etwas zu essen gibt.
Ich traue mich auch fast nicht ...
... ihn zu berühren.
Ich habe noch nie
so einen kleinen Menschen gesehen.
Er greift. Siehst du das?
Was denkst du ...
... leiden die Kinder auch, wenn sie
so viel zu früh geboren werden?
Ich finde,
man darf das nicht "leiden" nennen.
Die Frage ist, was das Beste ist ...
... das man in der Situation
für sie rausholen kann.
In diesem Moment,
wenn ich ihn so sehe,
würde ich nicht sagen,
dass er leidet.
Aber die zwei Jungs
hatten sicher schon Momente ...
Da ist aber das Wichtigste,
dass man schnell reagiert. Genau.
Hm?
Ich glaube, jetzt ist gut, oder?
- Super.
Du kannst die Spritze
einfach liegen lassen.
Ich spüle noch mit Luft nach,
damit auch wirklich alles
in den Magen kommt.
Soll ich das schliessen?
- Ja.
Mona, herzlich willkommen im Team.
- Danke vielmals.
Ich bin Philipp,
der Chefarzt der Station.
Freut mich. Wenn ich dich
als Fachmann fragen darf:
Wie geht es Yll jetzt?
Geht es ihm gut?
Hat er Aussichten
auf eine normale Entwicklung?
Kann man das schon sagen?
Auch wenn es noch
viel Intensivmedizin braucht ...
... erklären wir den Eltern immer,
dass das eine Treppe ist,
die sie erklimmen müssen.
Die Geburt und zu uns zu kommen
waren so die höchsten Tritte.
Jetzt müssen sie
die Treppe hochsteigen.
Sie werden immer mal wieder
ein paar Tritte zurückfallen.
Je weiter hinauf sie kommen,
desto breiter wird die Treppe.
Man kann also
immer weniger runterfallen.
Einfach ausgedrückt.
Er steht sicher noch
ziemlich am Anfang der Treppe.
Aber er hat die ersten,
grossen Tritte hinter sich.
Ich bin also optimistisch.
Die 24. Woche ist in der Schweiz
ja anscheinend eine Grenze.- Ja.
Haben solche Kinder schon überlebt,
als du Assistenzarzt warst?- Nein.
Als ich anfing, war die Grenze
in der Schweiz noch bei 26 Wochen.
Wir sind jetzt zwei Wochen darunter.
Es gibt Länder,
die noch deutlich tiefer gehen.
Japan geht bis zur 22. Woche.
Ich finde, man muss schauen,
was man erreichen kann.
Heroische Medizin,
bei der das Kind nur leidet,
finde ich nicht gerechtfertigt.
Es ist immer eine Gratwanderung:
Wie viel Risiko will man eingehen
und was will man dem Kind ersparen?
Ja.
- Ja.
Dann hoffen wir,
dass es mehr Hochs als Tiefs gibt.
Ja.
- Auf ihrem Weg.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Schon die erste Begegnung
auf der Neonatologie geht mir nahe.
Vielleicht auch,
weil ich selber zwei Jungs habe.
Zeit für eine Pause.
Es ist schön,
ohne Maske miteinander zu sprechen.
Ja, ich sehe dich zum ersten Mal.
Wie geht es dir, Mona?
- Das fährt schon ein.
Nur schon das Händchen ...
Das ist so klein.
Das berührte mich extrem.
Ich weiss, dass unsicher ist,
in welche Richtung es
bei den zwei Jungs geht.
Das berührt mich extrem.
Wie ist das bei dir?
- Das berührt einen immer.
Je mehr man schon gesehen hat ...
... desto besser kann man sich
seine Energie einteilen,
damit man nicht Panik schiebt
oder direkt schwarzsieht.
Jedes Kind zeigt
viele kleine, feine Kompetenzen.
Und es ist toll,
dass sie das schon leisten könne.
Du bist also eher Optimistin?
- Man muss optimistisch sein,
sonst darf und kann man
nicht hier arbeiten.- Ja.
So, wir gehen den Gang nach vorne.
Nach vorne zu den Kindern,
die schon etwas weiter sind.
Christian wartet auf uns.
Er kam in der
30. Schwangerschaftswoche zur Welt
und ist seit einem Monat
auf der Neonatologie.
Eigentlich wäre er
noch einen weiteren Monat im Bauch.
Jetzt gehen wir zu Christian.
Hallo. Du merkst noch gar nicht,
dass hier so viel los ist.
Er liegt auf einem Lagerungsmaterial
und ist noch fest eingekuschelt.
Damit die Kinder noch
möglichst entspannt sein können,
auch wenn man sie wickelt.
Also, damit sie sich wohlfühlen
und nicht im luftleeren Raum liegen?
Genau. Das könnte durchaus
auch belastend sein,
wenn wir da
ein bisschen Action machen.
Hallo.
- Hi, hi. Ja, schau nur.
Wir müssen noch den Schlauch ...
- Da ist ja jemand wach.
Hm?- Sag, hast du
deine Stöpsel selber ummontiert?
Hm?
Hm, Christian.
- Hoi, hoi.
Hm, bist du noch ein bisschen faul?
Ja. Traust du dich, ihm die Hose
auszuziehen, wenn ich helfe?
Ja, ja.
Vielleicht bin ich zu zuversichtlich.
Du sollst auch zuversichtlich sein.
Ich lege zuerst
noch eine Unterlage hin.
Ja, schau nur.
- Genau.
Du zeigst direkt
deinen sportlichen Puls.
Nicht, dass ich da ... Man hat Angst,
etwas kaputt zu machen.
Die sind so klein. Hm, schau mal.
Hm?
Hm? Ja? Wickeln wir?
Wir wollen die Belastung
immer gering halten.
Je höher die Belastung,
desto stressiger ist es
und desto mehr Kalorien
verbraucht das Kind.
Und das ist die Energie,
die sie noch nicht haben.- Mhm.
Schau mal, da ist etwas drin.
Hm, Christian?
Da ist etwas drin.
- Ich gebe dir Handschuhe.
Das Behandlungsteam wickelt immer
mit Handschuhen, die Eltern nicht.
Das habe ich
schon lange nicht mehr gemacht -
und bei so einem Kleinen noch nie.
Hm?
Gut. Du machst das gut.
Du bist ein absoluter Zuckerbollen.
Hm?
Wir sind zufrieden mit Mona, oder?
- Schau mal.
Christian erhält die Muttermilch
über eine Magensonde.
Aber er lernt schon
mit einem Wattestäbchen zu saugen.
Schau mal.
Hm?
Ja, schau nur.
Jetzt gehen die Augen auf.
Hoi, hoi.
Hm?
Saugst du ein bisschen? Hm?
Ja? Hm?
Ein bisschen. Ja, schau nur. Hm?
Das Stäbchen reinzuhalten,
ist eine Hemmschwelle.
Muss man es einfach
etwas reinschieben?
Oder nimmt er es selber?
- Wenn er so aufmacht,
will er wirklich, und du darfst.
- Ja.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Auf der Neonatologie
sind rund um die Uhr
Pflegepersonen,
Ärzte und Maschinen im Einsatz
für die kleinen Patienten.
Aber nichts kann die Bindung
und Berührung der Eltern ersetzen.
Darum legt man viel Wert darauf,
dass die Eltern die Kinder möglichst
bald in die Arme nehmen können.
Am Abend erhalten die Kleinen
am meisten Besuch.
Christian geniesst gerade eine Baby-
massage von seiner Mutter Susanne.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Im Zimmer nebenan treffe ich
auf den Papa der kleinsten Patienten,
den Zwillingen Yll und Trim.
Deine zwei Jungs sind die kleinsten
Menschen, die ich je gesehen habe.
Wir beide also.
Sind das deine ersten Kinder?
Nein, wir haben schon zwei Töchter.
- Okay.
Und jetzt noch zwei Jungs.
Wann hast du sie
zum ersten Mal gesehen?
Durftet ihr sie halten?
- Nein, nein.
So weit sind wir immer noch nicht.
Hast du sie noch nie gehalten?
Nur berührt.
Aber noch nie in den Armen gehalten.
- Ja.
Ich komme seit zwei Wochen
jeden Tag hierher.
Ich sehe,
was alles läuft und gemacht wird.
Das nimmt mir ein wenig die Sorgen.
Ich weiss,
dass sie in guten Händen sind.
Aber wenn ich sie so sehe,
ist das natürlich sehr speziell.
Mhm.
Könnt ihr als Eltern etwas machen ...
... um ihnen zu helfen?
Wir können und müssen
ihnen Kraft geben.
Kraft geben und da sein.
Alles andere ist Medizin
und der liebe Gott.- Mhm.
Ja.
Was bedeutet Yll?
- Stern.
Stern?
- Genau.
Und Trim?
- Trim, das ist der Mutige.
Der mutige, starke Trim.
Hat man euch gesagt,
wie lange sie etwa hier sein werden,
wenn alles gut läuft?
- Sicher drei bis vier Monate.
Aber ...
Ich habe mich darauf eingestellt.
Es soll einfach gut kommen.
Ich gebe ihnen auch mehr Zeit,
wenn sie die brauchen.
Sie sollen es einfach schaffen.
- Ja.
Ich drücke euch alle Daumen.
- Danke vielmals.
Ich wünsche euch alles, alles Gute.
- Danke.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ich gehe noch zu deinem Bruder.
Es wird eine ruhige Nacht
für alle auf der Neonatologie.
Wieder ein Tag mehr,
wieder ein Tritt weiter
auf der Treppe Richtung zu Hause.
Zeit für das Frühstück.
In der Milchküche wird die Mutter-
milch für die Kinder vorbereitet.
Sie kommt von den Müttern selber
oder von Muttermilchspenderinnen.
Als Erstes
besuchen wir heute Morgen Christian.
Guten Morgen.
- Hoi.
Morgen.
- Guten Morgen. Hallo.
Hoi, Christian.
- So.
Hast du schon gegessen?
- Ja, megagut am Schoppen.
Hat er am Schoppen getrunken?
- Ja. Megagut.
Ich schaue mal, wie viel.
Aber er macht das super.
Ihr fiebert mit jedem Baby mit.
- Ja.
Das sind kleine Siege für euch,
wenn sie trinken können usw.- Mega.
Es gibt ein Schoppendiplom.
- Genau.
Das kleben wir dann hin.
Dann sieht man, dass er schon
den ersten Schoppen getrunken hat.
Das feiern wir so. Genau.
Ein Schoppendiplom.
- Ja, genau.
Gestern
saugte er noch am Wattestäbchen,
bald hat er ein Schoppendiplom.
Grosse Schritte
für den kleinen Christian.
Im Bettchen nebenan kriegt Nick
Besuch von seiner Mutter Jasmin.
Nick wurde in der
33. Schwangerschaftswoche geboren.
Wie geht es euch?
- Gut.
Er erwacht langsam
und kriegt wohl etwas Hunger.
Nicht wahr?
Was waren die schwierigsten Momente
für dich?
Als er beatmet wurde,
fragte ich mich,
ob er wirklich irgendwann
selber atmen können wird.
Das ging drei Tage
und es hiess, die Maschine sei weg
und er brauche
auch keinen Sauerstoff mehr.
Wir waren sehr erstaunt,
dass er das schon konnte.
Das war einer der schönsten Momente.
Ich kam morgens hierher
und es war nichts mehr da.
Da merkte ich, dass es vorwärtsgeht.
Er hat so stark gekämpft
und konnte immer wieder etwas Neues.
Nicht?
Wo steht ihr jetzt?
Wir stehen an einem tollen Punkt.
Er muss
viele Voraussetzungen erfüllen,
damit er austreten kann.
Er hat schon fast überall
ein Häkchen.
Die Herzfrequenz
muss noch stabil werden,
dann dürfen wir bald nach Hause.
- Okay.
Genau,
wir kommen dem Austritt immer näher.
Hm? Bist du nicht mehr zufrieden?
Hm? Willst du etwas aufsitzen?
Ja, ui, ui, ui. Hm?
Ein bisschen aufsitzen?
- Hoi.
Uff, ist dir warm?
Hm?
Mhm.
Genau.
Das haben wir ab und zu gesagt.
Ich hoffe, dass ihr morgen
nach Hause könnt.- Wir auch.
Bis bald. Tschau.
- Bis bald.
Als Nächstes
geht es zu den Zwillingen,
den kleinsten Patienten
auf der Station.
Hallo. Machst du schon den Platz
für den Umzug bereit?- Genau.
Wir machen die Isolette hin.
Wer zieht um?
Trim wechselt den Platz.
Wir wechseln jede Woche die Isolette
und das Beatmungsgerät.
Und dabei richten wir den Platz neu
und wechseln das Kind.
In der warmen und feuchten Isolette
könnten sich mit der Zeit
Keime bilden,
die für die Frühgeborenen
gefährlich sind.
Ihr Immunsystem
ist noch nicht bereit,
um Krankheitserreger ausserhalb
des Mutterleibs abzuwehren.
Aber auch der Wechsel der Isolette
ist nicht ungefährlich.
Es braucht viele sorgfältige Hände,
um den kleinen Körper,
alle Geräte und Beatmungsschläuche
zu zügeln.
Ich nehme ihn zu mir.
- Eins, zwei, drei.
Eine falsche Bewegung
könnte verheerende Folgen haben.
Stephi,
das Absauggerät steht unter dir.
Kannst du es mir ...
Ja.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ich bin direkt hinter dir.
Damit die Kabel nicht zu stark ...
- Wie ist die Sättigung?
Ich habe die Beatmungsschläuche.
Nach konzentrierten Minuten
hat Trim es geschafft.
Seine Werte sind stabil.
Wie war es?
- Alles so, wie wir es wollen.
Genau.
Jetzt werden
noch alle Kabel sortiert.
Das dauert auch eine Weile.
Aber das Wichtigste ist,
dass er stabil ist.
Er hat das sehr gut gemacht.
- Ja.
Etwas nach oben.
- Ja, er hatte vorher 25.
Es geht schon nach oben. 27.
- Das ist gut.
Im Bettchen nebenan wird gerade
das Blut seines Bruders untersucht.
So, das ist fertig.
- Mhm, danke.
Bitte.
Super gemacht.
Yll hat sich in den letzten Tagen
gut entwickelt.
Er atmet ziemlich gut mit.
Wir geben ihm noch Zeit bis morgen.
Morgen entscheiden wir dann, ob man
ihn von der Beatmung wegnehmen kann.
Dann schauen wir.
So ein kleines Menschlein.
Was machst du jetzt?
- Einen Ultraschall am Kopf.
Ein Schädelultraschall,
mit dem wir das Hirn anschauen.
Wir schauen,
ob es sich normal entwickelt hat.
Insbesondere möchten wir sehen,
ob es keine Hirnblutung gegeben hat.
Hirnblutungen sind ein Risiko
bei extrem früh geborenen Kindern.
Weil die Hirngefässe so unreif sind,
kann es sein, dass eines platzt
und ins Hirn blutet.
Wenn Hirnblutungen beginnen,
würde man viel mehr Weiss sehen.
Das sieht gut aus.
- Mhm.
* Schnelles,
gleichmässiges Pulsieren *
Was ist das?
- Du hörst den Puls.
Ich mache eine Messung
an einem Gefäss im Hirn.
So sehen wir,
ob der Fluss normal ist.
Wenn man sehen würde, dass das Hirn
schwer beeinträchtigt ist:
Würde man dann das Gespräch
mit den Eltern suchen?- Ja.
Es führt kein Weg
an der Wahrheit vorbei.
Man muss erklären, was das
möglicherweise bedeuten kann.
Wenn es sehr schwerwiegend ist
und allenfalls sogar ...
Je nach Gesamtbild, also wenn das
Kind sonst noch schwer krank ist,
muss man sich überlegen,
ob es sinnvoll ist,
mit der Intensivtherapie
weiterzumachen.
Das sind schwierige Situationen,
die zum Glück nicht oft vorkommen.
Wann sagst du den Eltern, dass du
keine weitere Therapie empfiehlst?
Wenn das, was wir machen,
nicht zum Ziel Überleben führt.
Oder wenn etwas - wenn überhaupt -
zu einem ...
... schwer beeinträchtigten Leben
führt.- Ja.
Das ist der Punkt, an dem ich
mit den Eltern zusammensitze
und sage, dass ich Bedenken habe ...
... ob es wirklich sinnvoll ist,
die Therapie fortzuführen.
Das Leiden des Kindes
überwiegt dort dann.
Auf einer Intensivstation, auch wenn
man Schmerztherapie usw. macht,
werden selten angenehme
Interventionen vorgenommen.
Wer hat das letzte Wort?
- Prinzipiell die Eltern.
Ist es zumutbar, den Eltern zu sagen,
sie müssten sich dazu entscheiden,
das Kind gehen zu lassen?
Ja. Weil ...
... sie von Anfang an dabei waren.
- Ja.
Sie sind eng mit dabei
und sehen die Kinder.
Wenn wir den Vorschlage bringen,
ist es meistens so,
dass die Eltern das auch so sehen.
Sie wollen nicht,
dass das Kind noch weiterleidet.
Man muss ihnen aufzeigen ...
... dass es auch etwas Gutes ist,
das Leiden zu beenden -
auch wenn es für die rundherum
der härteste Weg ist.
Von den 650 Kindern,
die pro Jahr auf der Neonatologie des
Kantonsspitals Aarau betreut werden,
schaffen es fast alle, sagt Philipp.
Aber drei bis fünf Kinder pro Jahr
müssen die Eltern gehen lassen -
eng begleitet
vom Team der Neonatologie.
Abends gibt es wieder Besuch
der Eltern für die kleinen Patienten.
Man muss einfach beim Bein
darauf achten,
dass die Flügelchen
nach aussen gestülpt sind. Genau.
Er macht es so weit gut.
Von der Beatmung her
konnten wir reduzieren.
Wenn es so weitergeht,
versuchen wir morgen,
den Schlauch zu entfernen,
damit er selber atmet. Genau.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
In der Zwischenzeit
darf ich etwas machen,
das mich richtig freut:
Christian hat heute
seinen ersten Schoppen ausgetrunken.
Er erhält heute das Schoppendiplom.
Christians Mutter Susanne
ist gerade bei ihm.
(Stephi) Hoi, Christian.
Hast du gerade gegessen?
Er hat sein Schoppendiplom gemacht.
Er hat seinen ersten,
ganzen Schoppen getrunken.
Ah, so toll.
- Darum das Schoppendiplom.
So toll.
Hey, der erste, ganze Schoppen?
Hey.
Damit du gross und stark wirst.
Ich kann es dort hinhängen.
- Gerne, vielen Dank.
Wieder ein Meilenstein.
- Ja.
Das ist schön. So klein
und schon eine Auszeichnung.
Wie lange seid ihr schon hier?
- Vier Wochen.
Vier Wochen.
- Heute vier Wochen, ja.
Wie waren diese vier Wochen für dich?
Etwas surreal.
Es ist schon sehr komisch.
Man hat ein Kind,
aber es ist nicht zu Hause.- Ja.
Das ist ein wenig komisch.
Wenn man hier ist,
ist es wunderschön, aber komisch.
Ja.
Jedes Kind hat ein eigenes Tagebuch,
in dem alles drinsteht.
Darf ich reinschauen?
- Das sind seine Meilensteine.- Ja.
"Mit jedem neugeborenen Kind
geht eine kleine Sonne auf."
Jö.
Ja, hey, 30. Schwangerschaftswoche.
Sag: "Tschüss, Mama, bis später."
Jetzt machst du noch eine Bettpause
und Mami macht eine Kaffeepause.
Danke.
Aus Christians Tagebuch erfahre ich,
dass er einen Zwillingsbruder hatte:
Matthias.
Matthias
hatte schon im Bauch Organschäden
und verstarb leider
kurz nach der Geburt.
Susanne ist bereit,
mir mehr von ihm zu erzählen.
Als du deine ersten Kinder
geboren hattest,
hattest du als Erstes einen Abschied.
Ja.
Matthias lebte ja noch.
Ja?
- Es war schon auch ...
... schön.
Er gab Geräusche von sich.
Er weinte nicht,
aber wimmerte so vor sich hin.
Ich konnte seine Geräusche hören.
Das war ...
Ich hatte die Möglichkeit,
ihn so lange bei mir zu haben,
wie ich wollte,
um Abschied zu nehmen.
Ich hatte ja trotzdem
noch Christian.
Das hilft bei der Trauer.
Auch wenn es umso trauriger ist,
dass sein Bruder
nicht mit ihm aufwachsen kann.
Aber ich denke, jemand der ein Kind
gebären muss und gar nichts hat ...
Ich habe etwas,
auf das ich mich konzentrieren kann.
Er ist da
und erinnert mich immer an Matthias.
Wie geht es dir,
wenn du so darüber sprichst?
Darf ich das fragen?
- Das hängt immer vom Moment ab.
Manchmal besser,
manchmal schlechter.- Ja.
Ich spreche grundsätzlich gerne
über ihn. Er gehört für mich dazu.
Es fällt mir einfach
nicht immer gleich leicht.
Das glaube ich.
- Aber ...
Wir hatten zwei Jungs -
einen haben wir immer noch.
Ich bin froh, dass ich ihn
4 Std. lang kennenlernen durfte.
Mhm.
Das ist so.
Ja.
Abschied nehmen zu können
ist so wichtig.
Wir schalten gleich noch
das Licht ganz aus,
dann kannst du
eine richtige Ruhepause machen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Herrlich.
Mein dritter und letzter Tag
startet mit der Übergabe
vom Nachtdienst an den Tagdienst.
Guten Morgen.
- (Alle) Guten Morgen.
Wir haben aktuell sechs Patienten.
Vorne ist ein Platz frei
und wir haben zwei RSV-Kinder.
Es nimmt mich wunder,
wie es Nick geht.
Seine Mutter
war gestern ja optimistisch,
dass er bald nach Hause könne.
- Morgen, Sabrina.
Wie war es?
- Megagut.
Nick
hat alle Austrittskriterien erfüllt.
Yes.
Er darf definitiv nach Hause.
Ich habe seine Mami gerade angerufen
und sie freut sich extrem.
Super.
Danke vielmals. Schlaf gut.
- Gerne. Merci.
Das ist super.
- Ja.
Das war also
seine letzte Nacht bei euch.
Hoffentlich.
- Ja.
D.h., dass seine Mami
bald vollbepackt mit dem Maxi-Cosi,
den eigenen Kleidern
und ganz vielen Emotionen kommt.
Ja.
Ich gehe auch noch mal
bei den Zwillingen vorbei.
Für Yll ist heute
vielleicht ein grosser Tag.
Guten Morgen.
- Morgen.
In den letzten Tagen sah man
am Monitor und seinem Körper,
dass Yll versucht, selber zu atmen.
Das kann ein Zeichen dafür sein,
dass er bereit ist,
ohne Beatmungsmaschine auszukommen.
Bevor Philipp extubiert,
also den Beatmungsschlauch entfernt,
untersucht er Yll ganz genau,
um sicher zu sein,
dass er für diesen grossen Schritt
bereit ist.
Was ist deine Zwischenbilanz?
Bist du eher unsicher?
Gestern war ich sehr überzeugt,
aber was ich heute Morgen höre ...
Ich muss ihn untersuchen.
Dafür gehe ich zum Kind
und brauche da einen Moment.
Ich schaue natürlich auch
auf die Messwerte.
Aber das Kind und ich kommunizieren,
ohne miteinander zu sprechen.- Ja.
So kann ich die Einschätzung machen,
ob er bereit dafür ist.
Aber ich bin optimistisch.
In der Zwischenzeit
ist Nicks Mama Jasmin angekommen.
Nach einem Monat auf der Neonatologie
darf Nick endlich nach Hause.
Hoi, kleiner Mann.
Gehen wir nach Hause?
Ich freue mich richtig.
Dass Nick nach Hause kommt,
freut nicht nur die Eltern,
sondern auch
Nicks grosse Schwester Linda.
Sie lernt ihren Bruder heute
zum ersten Mal kennen.
Zurück bei Zwilling Yll -
viel Betrieb um sein Bettchen.
7,5 PIP.
- Sieben.
Maschine ausschalten.
Habt ihr euch entschieden?
- Ja.
Wir bereiten alles vor.
Der Wechsel von Beatmung auf Atem-
unterstützung soll zügig verlaufen.
Aber wir sind auch vorbereitet,
um wieder zu intubieren,
falls es nicht klappt.
- Muss man damit rechnen?
Ja.
Yll verschläft die Vorbereitungen.
Das Pflegeteam der Intensivstation
bereitet jeden Schritt genau vor.
Sobald der Beatmungsschlauch
entfernt wurde,
erhält Yll Beatmungsunterstützung,
muss aber selber atmen.
Es muss alles schnell
und gleichzeitig ruhig ablaufen,
damit Yll möglichst wenig Stress
und immer genug Luft hat.
Jetzt wird es ...
- Ich komme sofort rein.
Okay, gut. Also: extubieren.
Super.
* Verschiedene Pieptöne *
Ein bisschen zurück. Warte.
- Ja, ich ging vorher schon zurück.
Okay.
Atmet er jetzt selber?
- Ja.
Hallo, grüezi, Yll.
- Hey, das schaffst du. Super.
Gut gemacht.
- Jetzt geht es auf den Bauch.
Schau mal, wer alles da ist:
das ganze Team.
Hm?
* Lachen *
Yll hat es geschafft:
Er atmet selber.
Schön, oder?
Also, das ist wirklich
das Wunder des Lebens.
Philipp, hast du noch Zeit, um über
das Wunder des Lebens zu staunen,
trotz all dieser Technik?
- Ja.
Das gibt uns den Antrieb.
Immer wieder dieses Staunen.
Und manchmal auch das Traurigsein.
Aber meistens das Staunen.
Es sind diese kleinen Dinge.
Für uns ist eine Extubation
nichts Grosses,
aber der Erfolg
gibt ein gutes Gefühl -
für das Kind und einen selber.
Das Kind
hat einen weiteren Schritt gemacht.
Das ist ein grosser Tritt
auf der Treppe.
Wie verändert sich die Einstellung
oder der Blick aufs Leben?
Man hat dieses Bewusstsein:
Nichts im Leben
ist selbstverständlich.
Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass man auf die Welt kommen darf,
und auch nicht, dass man gesund ist
und direkt in den Flow des Lebens
und dieser Welt hineingeboren wird.
Es wird einem bewusst,
dass auch kleine Dinge
grosse Freuden sein können -
wie jetzt bei Yll.
Diese kleinen Schritte
sind das Leben.
Wir drücken die Daumen. Ging es gut?
- Genau.- Supergut.
Seid ihr zufrieden?- Ja.
- Ihr habt es auch gut gemacht.
Toi, toi, toi.
- Yll ist auf dem besten Weg.
Yll
hat einen grossen Schritt gemacht.
Ich verabschiede noch Nick
und seine Familie.
Wir sind startklar, genau.
- Gepackt und alles.
Ja, dick eingepackt.
Jetzt gehen wir nach Hause.
- Wie war das, als der Anruf kam?
Wahnsinnig schön.
Wir machten direkt einen Luftsprung.
- Du gehst jetzt raus.
Das wünschen sich alle Eltern hier.
- Genau.
Was macht das mit dir?
- Ich habe nur Glücksgefühle.
Man glaubt,
man könne gerade alles schaffen.
Man ist so glücklich.
Jetzt fühlt es sich komplett an.
Mach's gut -
auf dem Bauernhof zu Hause.
Und euch alles, alles Gute.
- Vielen Dank.
Einen guten zweiten Start zusammen.
- Danke schön.
Den werden wir geniessen.
So, Linda, schau mal.
Dann endlich ist die ganze Familie
Meier zum ersten Mal zusammen.
Schau mal.
- Ui, ui, ui.
Möchtest du ihn sehen?
* Nick gurgelt. *
Oh, ein grosser Schnaufer.
Möchtest du ihm den Igel geben?
Ja, er braucht ein Stofftier -
genau wie du.
Achtung, leg es so hin,
dass er noch etwas sieht.
Schläft er?
- Er schläft.
Ich wünsche euch einen guten
Familienstart zu viert. - Danke.
Einen guten Start.
Tschüss, Nick. Mach's gut!
Danke, dass ihr euch so gut um
unseren kleinen Mann gekümmert habt.
Ja, zu Mama.
Also.
- Also.
Nach drei intensiven Tagen auf der
Neonatologie gehe ich nach Hause -
mit viel Bewunderung für die Eltern
und auch für das Team,
die für diese kleinen Menschen
alles geben,
und mit einer grossen Portion
Respekt vor dem Leben.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Zwei Wochen später
erreicht uns eine traurige Nachricht:
Der kleine Yll,
einer der Zwillingsbrüder,
ist nach einer
schweren Darmentzündung verstorben.
Es ist der ausdrückliche Wunsch
seiner Eltern,
diesen Film trotzdem zu zeigen -
im Gedenken an Yll
und als Erinnerung
für seinen Zwillingsbruder Trim
und die ganze Familie.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022